>> Jesse: SUPREME COURT
HYPOCRISY ON FULL DISPLAY IN THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
LIBERALS GOING INTO OVERDRIVE
TRYING TO DEFEND BIDEN'S RADICAL
NOMINEE AND LOSING THEIR MINDS
ANY TIME SOMEBODY HAS THE NERVE
TO QUESTION HER RECORD AS A
JUDGE.
>> JOSH HAWLEY, FIST IN THE AIR.
SLAVEHOLDER DESCENDANT TOM
COTTON.
THEY WERE TREATING HER LIKE A
BLACK SHOPPER THEY WERE
FOLLOWING IN THE STORE.
>> GRANDSTANDING AND
SPEECHMAKING IN THE SENATE.
>> NO REPUBLICAN HAS BEEN MORE
HOT AND BOTHERED AND
LINDSEY GRAHAM OF
SOUTH CAROLINA.
>> THIS IS ABOUT MIDTERM
ELECTIONS, PUNITIVE CULTURAL
WARS, APPEALING TO THE G.O.P.
THAT'S INTO CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
>> SENATOR BLACKBURN'S LINE OF
QUESTIONING.
DID YOU SEE RACISM IN ANY EVENT?
>> Jesse: JESSICA, DID YOU SEE
ANY RACISM AT THE HEARING?
>> Jessica: NO.
I SAW A LOT OF STUFF I DIDN'T
LIKE.
I FEEL LIKE THERE WERE RACIAL
UNDERTONES TO IT.
THE ARGUMENT THAT HAS BEEN MADE
ABOUT THAT IS THAT TALKING DOWN
TO SOMEONE, AND YOU CAN
INTERPRET SOME OF THESE
QUESTIONS WHICH FEEL LIKE THE
GOTCHA QUESTIONS, COULD YOU
PLEASE DEFINE A WOMAN.
THAT THAT'S TALKING DOWN TO
SOMEONE AND WOULD THEY BE DOING
THAT TO A WHITE NOMINEE I THINK
IS THE LINE OF ARGUMENT.
I DID NOT SEE THAT.
I SAW SOME STUFF I DIDN'T LIKE.
I WENT BACK TO LOOK AT WHAT WENT
ON DURING AMY CONEY BARRETT'S
HEARINGS.
THE ADULATION FROM DEMOCRATS.
WE SAW CORY BOOKER GO OFF.
FILLED WITH JOY.
I MYSELF AM EXCITED ABOUT IT.
WE SAW SENATORS TILLIS,
GRAPHICALLY, GRAHAM GOING ON AND
ON.
AMY CONEY BARRETT IS A MOTHER.
SHE HAS SEVEN CHILDREN.
LINDSEY GRAHAM OPTED TO NINE
CHILDREN.
HAVE TWO MORE.
JOHN CORNYN HAD HER HOLD UP HER
BLANK PAGE OF NOTES.
>> Jesse: A NICE MOMENT.
>> Jessica: WHY IS IT A NICE
MOMENT QUESTION WHEN YOU THOUGHT
IT WAS COOL SHE DOESN'T HAVE TO
TAKE NOTES?
THAT SHOULD MAKE YOU MORE
QUALIFIED TO BE ON THE
SUPREME COURT?
>> Jesse: SHE KNOWS WHAT A
WOMAN IS.
EVERYONE DOES THIS.
THE DEMOCRATS.
THEY ARE NASTY WITH THE
REPUBLICAN NOMINEES.
VICE VERSA.
THE MEDIA ACT LIKE THIS IS THE
FIRST HEARING WE'VE EVER HAD.
>> Judge Jeanine: IT DOESN'T
TAKE MUCH TO SAY THAT THE WAY
THIS JUDGE IS BEING QUESTIONED
IS SO MUCH MORE POLITE THAN WHAT
THEY DID TO AMY CONEY BARRETT
AND WHAT THEY DID TO
BRETT KAVANAUGH.
IT WAS A CIRCUS.
LET'S ADMIT IT.
EVERYBODY SAID THEY DIDN'T
WANTED TO BE LIKE THAT.
THE REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN KIND
ENOUGH TO MAKE SURE IT ISN'T.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT, THE WHOLE
POINT OF THE QUESTIONING IS TO
GET AN IDEA OF WHO THIS GEORGES.
I JUDGE THAT REFUSES TO IDENTIFY
HER JUDICIAL PHILOSOPHY.
WE GO THROUGH THE TRUTH FINDING.
WE HAVE DONE IT FOR CENTURIES.
THE TRUTH FINDING PROCESSES WHEN
YOU PUT SOMEONE UNDER OATH AND
YOU ASK THEM QUESTIONS TO TRY TO
GET AT THAT TRUTH AND THAT'S
WHAT WE ARE DOING.
WE HAVE THIS CANDIDATE FOR THE
HIGHEST COURT IN THE LAND AND
WE'VE GOT TO ASK QUESTIONS.
SHE REPEATEDLY TELLS US HOW MUCH
SHE LOVES AMERICA.
EVERYBODY IS LIKE THIS IS
WONDERFUL.
SHE LOVES AMERICA.
THEN SHE ROUTINELY REFERS TO
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS AS WAR
CRIMINALS.
IT'S NOT JUST IN THE CAPTION IN
A LAWSUIT.
SHE REPEATEDLY TELLS US THAT HER
BROTHER IS IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND SHE KNOWS LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THAT'S GREAT.
THROUGH CROSS-EXAMINATION WE
FIND OUT THAT WITH CHILD
PORNOGRAPHY, SHE IS DOWN
SENTENCING BELOW THE SENTENCING
GUIDELINE.
LET ME TELL YOU WHAT CHILD
PORNOGRAPHY IS.
IT'S A VISUAL DEPICTION OF A
MINOR ENGAGING IN EXPLICIT
CONDUCT.
SHE CAN'T DEFINE WHAT A WOMAN
IS.
SHE COULD'VE SAID I AM A WOMAN
OR A WOMAN IS SOMEONE WHO GIVES
BIRTH OR ANYTHING.
SHE DOESN'T WANT TO BE UNMASKED.
LET ME FINISH.
CRT.
I THINK IT'S SOMETHING THEY
CHANGED IN LAW SCHOOL.
WE ALL KNOW IF YOU FOLLOWED ANY
OF THE NEWS IN VIRGINIA WAS
GOING ON IN THIS COUNTRY AND
IT'S NOT ABOUT LAW SCHOOL.
AND SHE'S ON THE BOARD OF A
SCHOOL WHERE THEY ARE TEACHING
CRITICAL RACE THEORY.
SHE HAS BEEN UNMASKED
DIFFERENTLY.
NOW WE FIND OUT HER PHILOSOPHY.
DOES THAT MEAN SHE WON'T BE A
JUSTICE?
SHE WILL BE BECAUSE THEY'VE GOT
THE NUMBERS BUT LET'S NOT KID
EACH OTHER.
IF SHE HAD BEEN HONEST IN THE
BEGINNING WE WOULDN'T OF HAD TO
GO THROUGH THE TRUTH FINDING
PROCESS.
>> Dana: I'M GOING TO CHANNEL
GREG GUTFELD AND TALK ABOUT THE
MEDIA.
GO BACK TO KAVANAUGH.
DO YOU REMEMBER WHEN THE MEDIA
WITH THE BIGGEST DRIVERS OF WEAK
RUMORS THAT THE MEDIA PUT
FORWARD AND THEN THEY HAD TO
WALK THEM BACK.
ALL OF A SUDDEN, THE SHE WAS ON
THE OTHER FOOT WITH JACKSON.
AND THERE IS NO INTELLECTUAL
CURIOSITY ABOUT ANYTHING THAT'S
GOING ON WITH SOME OF THESE
PERPETRATORS THAT SHE SENTENCED.
WHEN KAVANAUGH WAS UP, WE HAD
PROFILES OF EVERYONE HE HAD GONE
TO SCHOOL WITH SINCE PRESCHOOL.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" TODAY WAS
LIKE OH, REPUBLICANS EVENT SO
MUCH WORSE.
COME ON.
WHERE ARE THE PROFILES OF THESE
PEOPLE, ESPECIALLY THE ONES WHO
REOFFEND IT?
CURIOUS ENOUGH AS A JOURNALIST
THEY MIGHT WANT TO FOLLOW UP
THEY DIDN'T.
>> Jesse: THEY DIDN'T, DID
THEY, GREG?
>> Greg: THEY DIDN'T.
I SAW RACISM IN THAT MEDIUM
MONTAGE.
IF YOU CAN ASK TOUGH QUESTIONS
OF A PERSON OF COLOR, THEN
BASICALLY IT'S A FORM OF
BIGOTRY.
I KNOW THIS SOUNDS LIKE A RACIAL
TERM.
EVERY TIME YOU ASK A PERSON OF
COLOR CAUSES YOU TO BE A WHITE
KNIGHT, THAT MEANS YOU DON'T
BELIEVE THAT PERSON OF COLOR CAN
ANSWER THE QUESTION.
THAT'S WHY SEE.
I DON'T WANT TO GET TYRUS ANGRY.
IT'S LIKE PROFESSIONAL
WRESTLING.
WE ALREADY KNOW THE OUTCOME.
POLITICIANS ARE STILL PLAYING
THE ROLE.
THEY REVERSE EVERY TIME.
WE KNOW IT'S HAPPENING.
I THINK THE BEST WIN FOR
REPUBLICANS AND SOUL OF THE
DEMOCRATS WIN BECAUSE THEY ARE,
AS THE JUDGE SAID.
HOPE YOU'RE POLITE BEHAVIOR
MIGHT PAY A DIVIDEND LATER.
PROBABLY WON'T BUT MAYBE IT
WILL.
BUT AT THIS POINT YOU'RE FEEDING
THE MEDIA EVERY TIME YOU TRY TO
GRANDSTAND FOR A VIRAL MOMENT.
THAT'S WHAT CORY BOOKER LOVES TO
DO.
THERE'S A WEIRD AMNESIA.
I CAN'T TELL IF IT'S DELIBERATE
OR OBLIVIOUS THAT IN ORDER FOR
ALL OF THOSE IN THAT MONTAGE TO
ADOPT THAT STANCE, THEY HAVE TO
FORGET EVERYTHING THAT'S
HAPPENED IN THE LAST 30 TO 40
YEARS.
>> Jesse: I DO KNOW.
I THINK IT'S SMART OF YOU NOT TO
TRY TO GET TYRUS ANGRY.
BECAUSE HE WOULD CRUSH YOU.
LIKE A GRAPE.
>> Greg: BUT I WOULD ENJOY IT.
>> Jesse: YOU SIC